artemisa desea conocer el ancho del
cinturón de orión que es un cúmulo de
estrellas en la constelación de orión
ella ha determinado previamente las
distancias de su casa a aln y tak
setecientos treinta y seis años luz ya
mintaka 915 años luz las cuales son los
extremos del cinturón de orión ella
también sabe que el ángulo en el cielo
entre estas estrellas es 3 grados cual
es el ancho del cinturón de orión
esto es cuál es la distancia entre el
cni tac y mintaka y la respuesta no la
piden en años luz
hagamos un diagrama para cerciorarnos
que entendemos esto pero antes te invito
a que le pongas pausa el vídeo e intente
resolverlo por tu cuenta ahora sí
hagamos el diagrama supongamos que este
punto de aquí representa la casa de
artemisa vamos a ponerle la de artemisa
no mejor vamos a indicarlo bien vamos a
ponerlo como casa esa es la casa de
artemisa y artemisa que desea conocer el
ancho del cinturón de orión ha
determinado las distancias de su casa a
las estrellas que son los extremos de
ese cinturón de orión por un lado ha
determinado la distancia de su casa a
anita que obviamente esto nuestra escala
esta de aquí sería alnitak y también ha
determinado la distancia a mintaka que
es el otro extremo del cinturón de orión
así es que esta es mintaka sabemos
entonces que la distancia de su casa a
anita que esta distancia que tenemos
aquí la distancia a su casa y al cni tak
es de 736 años-luz nuestra unidad de
distancia es años-luz y también sabemos
que hay 900 15 años de su casa
aminta k es decir esta distancia que
tenemos aquí la distancia de su casa a
mitad k
900 15 915 años luz y deseamos conocer
el ancho del cinturón de orión que es la
distancia entre al cni tac y mintaka así
es que necesitamos determinar esta
distancia que tenemos aquí pero también
nos dan otra información nos dan este
ángulo de aquí este ángulo de aquí nos
indican que el ángulo en el cielo entre
estas estrellas es 3 grados así es que
este ángulo de aquí mide 3 grados
entonces cómo podemos calcular la
distancia entre la mitad y mintaka
llamémosle x a esta distancia como lo
hacemos bien si tenemos dos lados y el
ángulo entre ellos podemos usar la ley
de cosenos para calcular el tercer lado
para calcular este tercer lado así es
que apliquemos entonces la ley de
cosenos para este caso la ley de cosenos
establece que x cuadrada
a la suma de los cuadrados de los otros
lados
es decir x cuadrada es igual a 736
elevado al cuadrado + 915 elevado al
cuadrado
- dos veces el producto de 736 que
multiplica a 915 y que multiplica a el
coseno del ángulo el coseno de tres
grados
el coseno de tres lados de nueva cuenta
queremos encontrar la longitud del lado
opuesto al ángulo de tres grados
conocemos los lados que forman dicho
ángulo así es que la ley de cosenos
en que me quede una disculpa tuve que
toser fuera el micrófono
decíamos que conocemos el ángulo
conocemos los lados que conforman el
ángulo podemos conocer el lado opuesto
ese ángulo con la ley de cosenos que no
es muy diferente altura de pitágoras
incluye un ajuste pues éste no es un
triángulo rectángulo tenemos 7 100 56 al
cuadrado más 900 15 al cuadrado menos 2
veces el producto de los lados que
forman el ángulo multiplicado por el
coseno del ángulo o también podemos
escribir que x x es igual a eso está muy
grueso x es igual a la raíz de todo este
término déjame copiar esto que tenemos
aquí
copio
pero así es que x es igual a la raíz de
todo este término sacamos la calculadora
para hacer el cálculo verificamos que
esté en modo de grados y si
efectivamente está en modo de grados y
quiero calcular la raíz cuadrada de 736
al cuadrado mas 915 al cuadrado menos
dos veces 756 por 915
por coseno de 3 grados y eso me da igual
oigo sonar los redobles y que nos piden
nos piden redondear al año luz más
cercano así es que esto es 184 años luz
así es que x es aproximadamente igual a
184 años luz así es que a la luz le toma
184 años viajar de mintaka a alnitak
espero que este vídeo te haya enseñado
que si vas a hacer algo de astronomía la
ley de cosenos la ley de senos y en
general las técnicas de trigonometría
son sumamente útiles para hacer los
cálculos